Transcriber: gaith Takrity
المدقّق: Zain Al Amir Bourak
صباحكم و مساءكم و نهاركم فل
بداية أحب أن أشارككم بصورة تعني لي الكثير.
هذه صورة سوداء لا ترون
فيها شيء. كلنا نحب أن نتصور
وكلنا نحب أن نحفظ ذكريات
نعيشها مع أحبابنا وأصحابنا،
وخاصة الصور الجماعية التي نأخذها دائما
هذه واحدة من أهم الصور التي
في يوم من الأيام أخذتها .
كيف و لماذا و أين؟في يوم من الأيام
دعيت على العشا  من أصدقاء لي.
قالوا نسرين نريد أن نتعشى  في مكان
جميل كثيرا وطعامه لذيذ وجلسته رائعة.
فمثل ما كلنا يوم العشاء نرتدي أجمل ثيابنا،
ارتديت أجمل ثيابي و خرجت للعشاء.
عندما وصلنا للمطعم طلب
منا أن نضع جميع أغراضنا في الخزائن.
استغربت كثيرا،فأنا ذاهبة للعشاء ،
لماذا أضع أغراضي بالخزائن؟
لكن أحيانا أحب المفاجات
و حينها أحببت أن أتفاجأ.
فتح باب المصعد الذي يؤدي إلى المطعم ولفت
انتباهي أن هناك فتاة واقفة تنتظرنا فيه،
وكان من الواضح أنها كفيفة لا ترى.
أغلق باب المصعد ، وفجأة
أصبحت الدنيا ظالمة تماما.
لم أعد أرى أي شيء مطلقا ، وبصراحة لم أكن
مهيأة لهذا الموضوع ،
ولم أشعر باطمئنان، لم أشعر بالأمان،أردت
أن أعود أنا أخاف من الظلام،
كيف يحدث هذا؟
شعرت بخوف قليلا، قالت الفتاة أن يضع
كل شخص يده على كتف الذي أمامه.
كانت هذه الكفيفة واحدة من مجموعة من نوادل
كفيفين لا يرون مطلقا.
مشينا، وأجلست كل شخص منا على كرسيه،
و شرحت لنا الموجود على الطاولة أمامنا.
للوهلة الأولى أصابني حال من
الصمت والتشتت تماما .
صراحة أحسست أن كل شعوري
بالاستقلالية واعتمادي على نفسي يتبعثر،
يعني أنا لست نسرين .
أغلقت عيني قليلا، ولم يكن هناك فرق
لأنني بكلتا الحالتين لم أكن أرى شيئا،
المطعم عبارة عن سواد ظلام
دامس، لايمكن أن ترى فيه أي شيء.
قلت لنفسي هذه أكثر لحظة
تحرر ممكن أن أعيشها،
ليس ممهم ماذا ترتدين، ليس من المهم شكلك،
ليس من المهم ألوانك ،ليس مهم كيف تجلسين،
ليس من المهم كيف تأكلين بالشوكة
و السكين أم بيدك، فلا أحد يراكي.
وانصب كل تركيزي في تلك اللحظة
على الأحاديث التي كنا نتحدثها.
ولاحظت أن أحاديثنا ونحن لا نرى
بعضنا أصبحت أكثر عمقا و إثراء،
و أقل تكلفا من أحاديثنا
و نحن نرى بعضنا البعض .
أصبحت كل آرائنا وأفكارنا غير محكومة
لا بأحكام ولا افتراضات مسبقة،
تمليها علينا أشكالنا، لبسنا ،ألوانا،
طريقة جلستنا،وتصرفاتنا.
كان الشيء الوحيد الذي جمعنا حينها،
أننا كنا نعيش في عالم خالي
من القيود ومن الألوان الزائفة.
و من تلك اللحظة إلى الان أحتفظ بصورة من
هذا النوع لأنها معبرة جدا بالنسبة لي.
و من ذلك اليوم أسأل نفسي الأسئلة التالية.
ماذا يعني “normal and up normal؟”
ماذا يعني “able and disabled”؟
وكيف ممكن للممجتمع أن يصنف شخص أنه معاق،
بناء على عجز ما في جسمه
حصل لسبب ما في وقت ما،
ليس بناء على امكانيات وقدرات
يملكها هؤلاء الأشخاص،
قد لا نملكها نحن الذين نصنف
كأصحاء طبيعيين في المجتمع؟
اليوم يصادف اليوم العالمي
للأشخاص ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة .
هل تعلمون أنه يوجد مليار شخص في العالم
يعاني من شكل من أشكال الإعاقة؟
وهذا يعني 1 من 7 أشخاص في العالم،
ما يمثل نسبة 15 في المئة من سكان العالم .
في فلسطين عندنا هنا نسبة الأشخاص الذين
يعانون من حالة خاصة أو أكثر ستة بالمئة .
وإذا أخذنا حسب إحصائيات
المفهوم الأضيق لمعنى الإعاقة،
سواء إعاقة تامة أو شبه تامة،
تصل النسبة لاثنان بالمئة .
وقد تبدو هذه النسبة متدنية نسبيا ، ولكنها
تمثل تسعة بالمئة من العائلات في فلسطين.
بالرغم من كل المحاولات التي تحصل بكل الدول
لدمج هؤلاء الناس في مجتمعاتهم ،
إلا أنهم للأسف ما زالوا
يعتبرون  طبقة مهمشة .
التحديات التي تواجه الأشخاص
ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة في فلسطين كثيرة.
وتتعدد.من دمج في سوق العمل،
من الخدمات الصحية،
من التعليم، من المرافق العامة،
من البنية التحتية
لكن أنا أريد أن آخذ مثال
واحد لأنه مهم جدا.
التعليم .أكثر من ثلث الأطفال
فوق الثلاث سنوات لم يلتحقوا برياض الأطفال.
44 بالمئة من الذين أعمارهم بين 6 إلى 9 .
و 34 بالمئة من الذين أعمارهم من 10 ل15
وأكثر من 32 بالمئة من ال 16 سنة
لم يلتحقوا بالمدارس.
وأكثر من 39 بالمئة يتسربون من المدارس
ذوي الإعاقة الذين أعمارهم فوق ال16 سنة،
وهذا مؤشر على أن نظام التعليم عندنا
بفلسطين ما زال غير قادر
على إبقاء أكبر عدد ممكن من هؤلاء الأطفال
في مرحلة التعليم الإلزامي في المدارس.
السؤال الذي يطرح نفسه. لماذا؟
لماذا لا يزال هؤلاء الأشخاص يعتبروا
غير مندمجين في مجتمعاتهم ؟
هنالك عدة أسباب،
ولكن أولا: العالم بأكمله يتخطط
ويتصمم بناء على شيء اسمه
“main stream” الأغلبية.
تعلمون بالسياسة: الأغلبية، العادات
والتقاليد :الأغلبية، في كل شي :الأغلبية .
وبالتالي يتم تصميم وتخطيط البنية
التحتية وعالمنا وحياتنا اليومية
بناء على حاجة هذا الmain stream”
أو الأغلبية،
ويتم استثناء هؤلاء الناس وإمكانياتهم
وقدراتهم من هذا التخطيط.
ثانيا: الحكومات غير قادرة على توفير
جميع احتياجات هؤلاء الناس.
ثالثا: القطاع الخاص أكيد قطاع
ربحي، لا يوجد عنده
هذا الحافز القوي انه ينتج
حلول لهؤلاء الأشخاص،
لأن أسعارها سترتفع كثيرا،والطلب
قليل جدا،وقوتهم الشرائية قليلة،
وبالتالي تكلفة الإنتاج عالية،الطلب قليل
والأسعار سوف ترتفع،لن يستطيعوا.
وأهم جزء في الموضوع هو المجتمع،
وأنا هنا سوف أقول
أننا دائماً كمجتمع نلقي اللوم على
الحكومات والقطاع الخاص،
لكننا لانرى أنفسنا كباقي مجتمعات العالم
بأنه لنا دور في سد جزء من هذه الفجوة.
أين آلاف طلاب الجامعات
الذين يتخرجون كل سنة؟
اليوم ذكر الدكتور” محمد اشتية”
أعداد من المهندسين.
أين آلاف مشاريع التخرج التي تنجز كل سنة؟
أين تذهب؟ كيف نستفيد منها؟
ماذانفعل بها ؟
لو أتينا إلى المجتمع و قمنا
بتحويل حل من الحلول إلى نهج،
وقلنا أول شيء أن الأشخاص ذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصة هم أقدر ناس على معرفة حاجاتهم .
وهم أهم ناس يجب أن يكونوا جزء من
عملية تطوير أي منتج خاص بهم.
جلبنا هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين سأسميهم
“عارفي حاجاتهم” ليكون المنهج واضحا،
لأنهم يعرفون حاجاتهم.
ثانيا: لو ذهبنا إلى“الصناع“، من هم الصناع
المهندسين المتخصصين ذوي العلاقة،
المصممين،المطورين،
مهندسي التصميم الصناعي.
ثالثا: makerspaces مساحات التصنيع.
كل مراكز التأهيل ، الجامعات والمدارس
يجب أن يكون عندها ورشات عمل رئيسية،
يجب أن يكون لديها أدوات أساسية،
و إن لم تتوفر فيجب إيجادها.
رابعا: مقدموا الرعاية.
أي مراكز التأهيل والجمعيات
و المؤسسات التي تعني بهؤلاء الأشخاص،
خامسا: المستخدمين النهائيين.
وأريد أن أضع خطين على هذه الكلمة،
إذا قمنا بأنشطة مجتمعية مختلفة
وجمعنا فيها هؤلاء الناس،
وقمنا بتصاميم محددة لحاجة محددة
لشخص ذوي حاجة محددة ،
وكان هو جزء من تطوير هذا
المنتج بأقل التكاليف وأبسط المواد،
وتم تطوير هذه المنتجات وتصميمها وتصنيعها
كمحفظة منتجات رقمية كاملة وبالتوثيق الكامل
و رفع هذه التصاميم التي
يصممها  المهندسين و الكفاءات،
على مكتبة مفتوحة المصدر متاحة للجميع.
ليس من عنده احتياج خاص في فلسطين فقط
يمكنه أن يذهب إلى هذا الموقع
و يقوم بتنزيل لكل الملف،
ويذهب لأي ورشة تصنيع فيها أي شيء بسيط،
أدوات بسيطة، ويقول له صنعلي هذا الحل.
وهناك الكثير من الأمثلة و الحلول ممكن تكون
مخصصة ومعدلة بما يتناسب مع حاجة كل شخص.
و إذا دخل الشخص ووجد مئة منتج على
هذا المصدر المفتوح ولم يجد الحل فيها،
يستطيع أن يرسل طلبا
بتفاصيل التحدي الذي يواجهه،
ونقول ل“جماعة التطوير”
كونوا مبدعين
لديكم تحدي جديد.
وهكذا.
لذلك أنا أسمي هذا النهج “محور الإنسانية”
ليس معناه أنه يحل مشاكل الإنسانية،
لكنه يركز على حاجة شخص عنده حاجة محددة،
ولكن هذه الحاجة محددة ممكن أن تستخدم
من قبل الاخرين محليا ودوليا.
من خلال تجنيد وتكثيف الجهود
و المهارات الموجودة في المجتمع مع بعضهم .
اذا خلقنا لهم الأساس البسيط
الذي لا يحتاج إلى استثمار كثير.
الذي يلتقون بوقائع
اجتماعية ويطورون هذه الحلول.
الوصول العالمي لإبتكاراتنا كفلسطينيين
المفروض أن تفيد المجتمع الفلسطيني والعالم
أيضا نحن جزء من منظومة عالمية .
هناك الكثير من الأمثلة.
أنا شاركت في ورشة تصنيع سريعا لمقاعد
متحركة لأطفال أعمارهم من سنتين لثلاث سنين
أعطينا التصميم جاهزا من طلاب
جامعات متطوعين،وصنعنا ثلاث كراسي
اشكالها و ألوانها مثل الألعاب، هي العاب
تبرعنا بهم لأطفال عاجزين
عن السير بعمر سنتين لثلاث سنوات.
في مركز تأهيل .
صدقوني الأطفال الأصحاء أرادوا استخدامه
أكثر من الأطفال العاجزين عن السير.
وشعر الطفل العاجز بأنه
مميز وليس اقل من غيره.
هذا الكرسي الذي انتجنا منه ستة والذي شارك
في تطويره وتصنيعه وتصميمه
شباب جامعات مشاريع تخرج.
هل تعلمون كلفة الكرسي الواحد
للمستخدمين النهائيين؟
لا يتجاوز الخمسين ستين دولار.
بينما إذا أردت إحضار مقعد متحرك من شركة
عالمية تصنع هكذا أشياء لطفل عمره سنين،
كم ستكون كلفته؟وكم عائلة تستطيع منحه؟
وهناك مئات و الاف الأمثلة غير ذلك.
أشخاص كانوا يركبون الأمواج
و فقدوا أطرافهم،وجد لهم حلول.
شابة فقدت يدها،وهي تعزف على الكمان
وأرادت ان تكمل موهبتها،وجد لها حل.
امرأة تستخدم قشارة البطاطا،فقدت أصابعها
فكر زوجها كيف من الممكن ابتكار آلة تساعدها
قام بتطوير أداة بسيطة جدا،
هناك شركة بالعالم تقوم ببيعها
أونلاين ويستخدم
من قبل الأشخاص مبتوري الأصابع
والأشخاص العاديين في بيوتهم.
فهي “محور إنساني”
ومن الممكن استخدامها عالميا،
بحلول بسيطة وبتكاليف قليلة .
هناك شيء أخير ارغب أن أقوله،حتى سلوك
المجتمع ممكن أن يتغير من أمور بسيطة.
هناك الإشارة المعروفة للشخص العاجز
لمواقف السيارات في المناطق العامة،
والتي تظهر أن هذا الشخص
سلبي،عالة،ضعيف،عاجز.
وهناك حركة عالمية تطالب بشعار
جديد وأصبح يطبق في بعض الدول،
تريك الشخص على المقعد المتحرك
وكأنه يركض ويتحرك.
وعندما نرى هذه الإشارة وليس تلك.
نعرف أنه شخص معتمد على نفسه
ومرتبط ونشيط جدا وأنه جزء من المجتمع.
الأشخاص ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة ليسوا
عاجزين،ولكننا كمجتمع نجعلهم عاجزين .
استثناء هؤلاء الناس من المجتمع هو ليس
فقط خسارة لإمكانيات وقدرات.
و بالمقابل عدم استثنائهم،
هو ليس فقط واجب اجتماعي وأخلاقي .
هو واجب اقتصادي أيضا .
منظمة العمل الدولية في أحد تقاريرها أشارت،
إلى أن استثناء الأشخاص ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصة من سوق العمل،
يسلب هذه الدول ما يقارب سبعة
بالمئة من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي .
إذا الموضوع ليس من باب
المساواة والعدالة فقط،
هو أيضا من باب الاستثمار
في البلد من قبل شريحة البلد تستثنيها.
الإعاقة ليست بشخص فقد شيء .
الإعاقة قد تكون في القوانين والسياسات
والإجراءات والبيروقراطية المفرطة،
التي من الممكن أن تكبت كل قدرة موجودة
عند شخص منا و تجعلنا معاقين.
فان الأوان أن نرتقي و نفتح
الأبواب للإبداعات و الشباب،
والأفكار الخلاقة الموجودة
في كل شرائح المجتمع،
وإلا سيصيب الشلل التام
شغف الكثيرين منا في هذا البلد .
شكرا .
“تصفيق”